oh oh no no no no no
oggi berlino ha rubato il posto di
evitare ma giocheremo io berlino lira
d'ore a sedersi nella sedia qua al
tavolo perché anche lui vuole fare la
youtuber vero berlino dormendo grazie
alla lino oggi a grandissima richiesta
tornano i giochi può quindi se vi
piacciono le cose paurose come a noi
sapete che la mia
adoriamo le cose paurose le cose horror
le cose spaventose questi giochi vi
piace e alla fine del video scriveteci
qual è stato il vostro preferito di
questi tre giochi e se volete dare un
punteggio da 1 a 10
a ogni giorno e daremo un voto da 1 a 10
a ognuno di questi giochi siete pronti
ma se come mi piace facciamo raggiungere
questo video e 10 mila mi piace per un
altro episodio di giochi spaventosi anzi
se ne conoscete ma non siete altri
giochi paolo di scrivere silicio ovvero
se volete che proviamo scrive di sé di
tutti dei commenti mettetevi comodi
prendete i porta nel primo gioco
iniziamo da meno pauroso più quadrata
questo gioco in pratica è con un ragno
se vi fanno paura ai vari invertire i
ragni che 2000 più paolo veneto fanno
paura era già allora però queste cose
qua c'era scritto all'inizio del gioco
di non farle alta perché sono pericolosa
che fa di questo gioco se ho capito bene
dobbiamo rincorrere un ragno e farlo
fuori
poveri poveri infatti il gioco si chiama
uccidi o col fuoco per ogni volta che
troviamo un ragno qua in casa
chiedo vitale di prenderlo a portarlo
fuori perché mi dispiace non voglio che
venga ucciso poverino spesso in questo
gioco dobbiamo proprio farlo fuori
aiuto è stata mente non potrò a casa e
non invitate queste cose pericolose
prodi e così qua allora immagino che
siamo in casa nostra e dobbiamo trovare
il ragno bomba viagrande
tra l'altro questa è una situazione che
succede spesso lo trovi un ragno in casa
poi scompare è già un sacco di ansia e
di paura perché non fai dove è finito
avvenuto invece c'è un posto hanno
trovato affari cedono ritroviamo pillolo
mano quando bisogna colpirlo dice di
prendere la clip ecco certo senza la
clipboard è così che quando devi
schiacciare con quella no non l'ho preso
con maccarone va velocissimo come i
ragni non è mai arrivati cappato che
cosa ecco le titolate i canili avviato
lunghi che no non l'ho visto che lo so
eccolo va il premio
penso che questo gioco pavé di grazia è
scappato c'è questo qui prediamo questo
che cosa
lo possiamo usare per trovare gli altri
anni ecco il farro preso no ma ancora
vivo devi fare qualcos'altro sono più
forti questo nuovo obiettivo dobbiamo
uccidere uno dei ragni con le prove di
avuto però tutto ciò abbiamo fatto il
callo
in questa stanza più spostato tutto nord
si che un gioco paolo ma questo era più
grosso 30 torosidis costo sicuramente io
sono stato lo è ancora con vicino curati
bene intorno
vediamo se ancora accadere davvero io la
morfina perché ranieri quasi
si dicono tante cose per terra che si
conosco dunque guardate il disastro che
abbiamo fatto solo per rendere fa no non
ho preso spettacolo sia faticoso verde
ma quante volte mio veniamo a pirlo per
eliminarlo ma sbaglio lucera e lo nei
borro in quel ritratto guarda guarda
no no no in un altro brano qua questo
forse un piano di hello naipaul acqua
nella casa di quattro anni basta via
maragno aiuto viene chiuso dalla porta
abbiamo sbloccato il bagno ma ovviamente
altri ragni guardano sabbia
cosa possiamo fare lanciafiamme questo
fuoco al muro posso mettere a fuoco
tutta la casa siamo spacciati c'è
scritto che dobbiamo bruciare 20 oggetti
che succede se un raggio del suo
gabinetto aprì uno che facciamo non
usando perfetto da fare nel mondo il
pavimento anche bene forse meglio
scappare da questo bagno sarebbe un
lavandino e lucia indiano che scappava
capo di noi discutiamo diamo paurosa
vinto gioco per uso volte farà strada
che aveva visto su un altro livello
allora abbiamo messo minuti abbiamo
eliminato dissi allora che già vediamo
al gioco del ragno allora perché è
troppo divertente cioè è semplicissimo
l'idea però può venire comunque altre
perché di ritrovare iraniche di
nascondere deve anche divertente io sì
se no nove e mezzo perché è troppo
divertente mi piacerebbe giocare ancora
gli altri livelli
non ci siamo lasciati belli piace
scrivete il vostro voto nei commenti ora
passiamo le cose secondo gioco allora
questo fino amministrando melo 6 cala
della paura stiamo andando pietro feste
più paurosi attenzione si chiama mister
fox come potete vedere li affiancano il
cattivo è un coniglio scoperti siete
pronti iniziamo a stasera non voglio
dormire con signor hop mi fa paura paura
e il padre risponde non essere sciocca
ruby ti lascia la luce notturna al senza
cerca di riposare e questa la luce
notturna che
oh oh no no no no no ok
eccoci qua obiettivo vai nella camera
dei tuoi genitori
sicuramente dovremo evitare questa
occupazionale problemi di gioco e stile
se sono ruby avesse dato ascolto ai suoi
genitori ha rimesso a posto i giocattoli
supera con un salto i giochi disseminati
per casa i rumori potrebbero vincere
affitto che dobbiamo evitare i giochi
per non fare rumore non far arrivare il
mister dopo che questo coniglio malefico
che non ho capito se un peluche forse un
pupazzo manico vediamo che cosa c'è
mamma ogni segno ruby c'è il padre la
madre guardavo malefico regno ha fatto
il triste visto e ho paura che spunti
fuori all'improvviso c'è scritto ai
pasti fanno rumori assicurati che non ci
siano pericoli sapeva la coppia ha detto
consiglio ascolta ascolta attentamente i
rumori tornate vediamo dove abbastanza
forse questa la stanza mamma papà dove
siete
o li apprese viste rob torna a letto
no ma come non c'è nessuno qua non per
niente si può tornare indietro
ora sia un graffio panel via freddi
mister o attento evita i giochi no ma
non mi dire che per la libia
obiettivo e 16 anni
questo non va beh papà mamma mia
questo coniglio suo caso non c'è un
patto sulla banchina non si va da
nessuna parte
questo è uno di noi abbiamo provato
anche se la grafica è molto molto
semplice perché tipo stile giochi anni
80 che comunque bellico sia storico che
hanno data però fa comunque un sacco di
paura perché di fare silenzio non deve
schiacciare cose poi lui e se vuoi
all'improvviso fuori e poi prima di non
è un peluche perché fine sogni d'oro
ruby racconta si trattasse solo di un
brutto sogno è tornata a letto forse è
stato un errore abbiamo perso perché il
motore del mezzo secolo di un sogno
quindi noi dobbiamo tornare a dormire
perché ci prende ok facciamo che se
questo video raggiunge i 15 mila mi
piace faremo mister hop nella vita reale
così ce la facciamo paura
ha preso i proviamo dobbiamo uscire vita
sono caduto su un giochino prova questa
e altre scale ora l'inter dice un pò
sempre sul televisione
ok tornasse si può andare da credo che
la camera dei genitori
ok abbiamo scoperto un nuovo area premi
giù per accucciati dietro immobili
ok nas con divide tra chi non ce l'ha
visto non ci ho visto la sua persona
turistici nascondiamo borghese come lui
dall'altra parte a tre fa ha sollevato
il dito mi ha preso il frattempo in
tutto ciò nonostante le 93 url e
spaventi merlino dorme profondamente 16
st scappato sul tema da sviluppare
ok allora treviso g chart i rumor pini
questo abbiamo fatto
[Musica]
no non ho capito il telefono perché non
ha funzionato prima è scomodato si sono
spostati per un pelo e tipo credi che va
benissimo fuori quindi stare tutto
l'assetto ok ok allora siamo in un'altra
stanza
non ci ho visto non c'è rispetto questo
è uscita mamma mamma cerca la mamma
forse cotesto alcune porte richiedono
una chiave dobbiamo trovare la chiave
che fa 4 vale armati studiava ok
prendila dei provocatori so già che mi
paradosso allora ho preso la chiave e
attenta perché lui poi a lui era vicino
a è stata molto molto fortunata attenta
è passato da dietro è ancora lì che
aspetta è mai adesso vai che non ti vede
[Musica]
abbiamo tutti bloccare abbiamo in cui si
no l'ontario dovuto restare facevo tutto
buio aiuto non si vede niente
così è questa il registratore in un
bigliettino da casa si legge sotto allo
specchio anniversario 18 aprile
questi sono tutti indizi ricordiamoci di
tutti per 14 secondi non c'è perché
allora l'obiettivo è trovare i nastri e
abbiamo già visto che uno dovrebbe
essere sotto allo specchio del bagno se
non troviamo
come ascoltarsi 18 settembre ieri io
gene ruby siamo andati a trovare esser
ruby ad ora far visita show non ha però
ester negli ultimi mesi non sembra stare
molto bene lo scorso fine settimana
l'abbiamo trovata intenta a fissare il
muro abbiamo dovuto scuoterla perché
tornasse in sé ma dopo si è comportata
normalmente mi chiedo da quanto tempo
fosse in quello stato ogni modo le
abbiamo prenotato una visita dal dottore
nel frattempo deciso di registrare
alcune idee per un nuovo romanzo che
cosa strana master siamo noi la bambina
no ruby la bambina estero e la nonna
quindi è la nonna che curava verso il
muro forse perché avete viste rock
forse perché mister o poi gli hanno dato
la nonna quindi ecco perché fe no me è
rimasta scioccata da mister hop della
nonna ci ha dato a noi adesso ce
l'abbiamo noi perché la nonna gli ha
dato vita a questa e malefico perché
forse mister oppo era già all'interno
del cervello della nota la nuova era
cattiva lo stesso e non lo so però eroi
dovevo pensate cosa
secondo voi dietro a questa storia
perché intrigante adatto ma so che ne
abbiamo uno di sei dobbiamo trovarne
altre 56 se riusciamo dove sarò a lui è
ovviamente qua dietro
[Musica]
se lo scampato per un pelo
se uno porta o lui può vederci lui si
può vedere bene allora chi votiamo
queste dieci moro veramente lido un 9 e
mezzo perché la storia super intrigante
e super spaventoso mister o poi su
persone
mi piace un mistero da risolvere anche
queste cose le vogliamo attirare voi che
voto gli date scrivetecelo nei commenti
e lasciato un mi piace se volete che lo
continuiamo un ora passiamo il testo e
molti bomber ha più paura di bizet robot
auguriamo la fiera prossimo gioco questo
gioco si chiama i voodoo quindi bambola
cagati descritto giorno 1 quindi penso
che sarà simile a graham infatti si
somiglia green in un senso sono gli
stessi creatori non solo a far sorridere
a leggere bona gel che abbiamo fare
attenti alla bambola perché si sentono i
passi quindi attenzione pensi dei pasti
nasconditi che ci possiamo nascondere
era molto simile a g che cosa dovremmo
fare però forse eliminare la bambola
cattiva gloriamo esploriamo sicura che
spunterà fuori all'improvviso
io avrei paura a stare qua è un altro
passaggio segreto questo giustamente se
sei entrato in passato sta creando cifra
deve uscire dice deve essere pure
riuscito e ha molte idee visto che
brutta che era quella barba tutto questo
per monica lento almeno è lento e non è
come granny che corre ma che bel bagno
pulitissimo allora devi stare attento
il rumore dei passi perché quando sia il
rumore dei pasti vuol dire che lui è
vicinissimo e bisogni ha stupito
nasconderci ma detestati risuona
tassativo anche perché vuoi bagno non
mai era molto sporco perché se lo
statino in corto gioco parte di aiutarlo
bambola in bagno che posso mettere qui
il pezzo di fucile intanto va bene ma
mancano gli altri paesi dobbiamo cercare
ancora che c'è questo è un fungo al coro
arcobaleno ma servirà marcobaleno così
forse un po pericoloso forse è velenoso
e allora possiamo dare sia il fungo
velenoso che la fattiva una pazza non la
rivedremo mai
[Musica]
metti soli fanno troppa paura ma verrà
fatto un altro proiettile alfredo
salento che siamo riusciti a eliminarla
addetti data per qualche secondo
bene nascondi di una bassa è ancora lì
per terra non ci credo quando c'è un
coltello va letto che paura non c'è più
ricco in giro ho paura adesso popolo
dovevamo fregarsi lo scempio sotto
misura ma per fortuna è lentissimo la
porta dai te lo puoi fare a colpirlo
ricaricare ok continua ad esplorare nel
frattempo che la bambola sta dormendo
non era notista lavanderia una ciotola e
un panino e provincia per queste cose
dice di mettere lassativa e la satira in
italy inglese dovevo fare adesso la
banca
dai sbrighiamocì arrestato arm e ricordi
dove stavo le ragioni in cantina e
lassativo
voglio però si è passati voci hanno
lasciato lì perché vado a prendere il
fucile o troppo poco ma soldi ti
nascondi si ok abbiamo messo il panino
quindi ora dove scappiamo burger con la
crono beh non ci posso credere
meno male è stato ormai no forse
finalmente arrivato il bagno kostelic e
le prove sul tavolo è una chiave
sì forse era la chiave decise ma
l'abbiamo vista aspetta che lascio
questa diceva di mettere un contenitore
per l'acqua per pulire la cache questo
68 58 codice
ciao preso perché voti diamo cosi a te
li do un otto e mezzo perché oltre a
essere pauroso era anche divertenti
siete invece anche a me è piaciuta
tantissimo poi prende bene quei suoni la
musica e tutto quanto non è che voto gli
date scrivetelo nei commenti e
scriveteci quale è stato il vostro gioco
preferito il mio è stato mister pop eye
to anche per me è stato mister opera
davvero super bello anche questo però ed
a continuare
vi lasciamo a 4 da due linee su cui
cliccare per veder inoltre altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite
[Musica]